Did everyone get a brownie?
They're awesome brownies.
You might sugar crash a little bit but they're
definitely worth it.
I definitely recommend it if you have haven't
gotten one.
So continuing our awesome ladies' block here
at the Side Track, we have Monica who is from
San Francisco, and she can be best described
as screaming-cat-face-tada emoji.
So please welcome Monica.
Aw, man, I didn't realize that this was the
women's block, but I'm super excited to talk
today because the only thing that would make
this talk more would be cats.
So here's a little tiny one.
Hi, everyone, I'm Monica, and I'm notwaldorf
on GitHub, and I work with Polymer and I'll
talk about that later because now I'm going
to talk about art.
So before I became a developer, I was convinced
that I would become an architect because all
of my life, I drew ammunition and I painted
things and I really liked making art.
But it turns out that art is kind of hard.
My kitchen is now covered in, like, tiny little
pots because I can't make, like, cups that
are human sized yet because I don't know how.
So I just have cups for dolls right now.
And so art is really hard.
And even if you're a really talented painter
like van Gogh, even if you're naturally talented.
When -- you start having different problems
like my composition is off, my colors are
off.
It doesn't express the thing that I really
want.
This time at Christmas, like, 15 years ago,
I came home and my mom was, like, oh, I gotta
show you this thing that I discovered and
she shows me this amazing painting of a landscape,
or a street in Paris, I don't remember.
Not a talented person.
She's not an artistic person.
She can draw.
And I said, how have you managed to produce
this?
And as it turns out, it was a paint by numbers.
And that's what I realized was that people
really enjoy making art, even if they're not
good at it if you give them the right tools.
So in this case, paint by numbers is really
good if you're not talented.
It restricts the problem to something really
small and in the end you get this awesome
thing that looks pretty and then you get to
show it to people.
Because art is fun.
You get to make things, you get to spend a
little bit of time and produce something.
And sharing art is really fun.
She didn't, like, make this painting and,
like, hide it away in the basement.
She showed it to me and said, look at this
thing I made I'm awesome.
I'm van Gogh.
She's not.
And we know sharing art is fun because who
here has -- raise your hand if you've never
taken a photo and put it on the Internet.
Yeah, nobody -- everybody takes photos and
you put them on the Internet so all your friends
see them.
There's a whole industry of apps that put
filters on your Instagram photos so that they're
pretty and artsy.
Last year, this, like, app came out that was
called Prisma, and it made everything look
like a painting and it was super popular for
three weeks.
Because we like making shit and saying, look at what
I made, look at my artistic talent.
And do you know what's good about sharing?
All of these things are on the web on this
fantastic cloud we have, we don't print them
out and give them to people anymore, we put
them on the website.
So I'm going to show you some things that
I've put on the web.
So the first thing one is something called
Octopus Holdings.
So John and I'm going to butcher his last
name, Hergenrother, basically made this thing
where you could represent words in an URL,
so this is cat using a necktie with pants
on an elephants and it's really easy to share
because you can show people what you made.
And it's very easy to understand because the
problem of you making art is very simple.
You can only, like, use emoji and it's really
amazing.
It's kind of fun, you get to make fun things.
The reason that it's called An Octopus Holdings
is because if you don't make anything, it's,
like, an octopus holding a trophy.
It's awesome.
Jen Schiffer made think project, pixels are
easier, there's fewer of them.
You can increase the resolution.
The colors are more limited and you get to,
like -- this is my attempt to draw a cat and
it's terrible.
But the reason why I know it's really fun
and people really like it, and, again, people
really like sharing this art, is that a lot
of people will tweet at her and say, look
at this thing, I've made a Make Art to work
on a game for a kid who's six.
And this is amazing, we're, like, exposing
kids to making art with code and technology
early on, which is kind of awesome.
On a similar vein, my friend Wan made this
Mega Emoji, where instead of drawing with
art, you do it with emoji.
So that takes another real world thing like
tracing.
Sometimes you'll trace it on a piece of paper.
So this is a lot like that.
I had a really bad day once, so I spent an
hour making dumb shit.
This is a cat that I've made out of emojis
using Mega Emoji and it was really fun because
it was really simple and I just traced the
cat emoji.
And now and, like, it all circles out, I started
out with emojis, and then the drawing, and
then back to emoji.
This is Emojibrush that Sam Sico made, and
it's literally a canvas and you draw with
emojis and that's all you do.
And people use it to make dumb things with
it.
I think Kia, she's @LadyLead on Twitter.
And she would say, I made your Twitter on
Emoji Brush.
And this is really fun because it's a really
easy and, like, a joyful project to do.
And the reason I'm telling you all of this
because I think we're really good at making
art more accessible and more friendly by giving
them better brushes.
We've, like, learned this over the years.
We have color by numbers, we have tracing,
we have all these other apps that make it
really easy for you create things.
And so if you believe me that's true, I think
the same thing is true for the web, the web
can be more accessible, and fun, and by that
I mean, making things on the web can be more
accessible and fun if you give them better
brushes because the same argument can be made
for both things.
And by better brushes, it's like making a
better div because I like the div because
it's like the pen and pencil, you still have
to learn how to hold the div, and vertically
size it, and how to center it, and all sorts
of things like that.
So the web is really good at semantics.
And in HTML 5, we've got awesome things like
header, and nav, and article that tell you
what those elements do.
They don't look any different.
They just look like, you know, divs of text
but at least they tell what they're supposed
to do.
So if you put a header, that should probably
be at the top, and the article somewhere in
the middle, and then the footer at the bottom,
and the future you is going to read this page.
It would be much easier if you had a pile
of divs where hopefully you put a class="header"
somewhere so that you knew that I meant to
put this at the top.
The other thing that the web is really good
at is encapsulation and this is one of my
favorite things about the web.
So there are, like, these magical elements
in the browser that do magical things, like
video, or input, like input has 21 different
types and you can do color picking and input
different files but you don't have to wonder
how they're implemented, they just come to
you and you're like, sweet, this is amazing.
But if you peek inside of them, if you go
on Chrome, and you look at enableShadow Roots,
if you look at, it's a content-editable div,
that's pretty cool.
There's one that lets you put a number on
it, a number flicker that goes up and down,
it's already more complicated.
It has some pseudos in it
that can be, like, a bridge that's like, I
really need to style this spin button and
the reason why this is important because these
divs and these styles don't go outside of
the input element.
That's why you can't reach and style everything
in it.
You can only style things that, like, that
element really wants you to style.
And that's why encapsulation is awesome.
So something like a video element is actually
ginormous and terrifying.
It's got, like, ranges and buttons, and a
shit ton of divs and yeah.
So cool, encapsulation is really awesome.
So if semantics are awesome and encapsulation
are awesome, that means that we can, like,
keep waiting and it's going to give us something
like a Emoji Brush, it's semantic expressive,
and it's emoji, and it's impressive because
it's impressive how God knows how Sam implemented
this.
But we can't just put an emoji brush in Chrome,
that's not a thing that we can do.
But that's why I like web components.
It takes semantics and ability that the browser
already has and giving it to you as developers
so that you can use them yourselves.
And the components are not special by themselves.
The reason why web components are really awesome
is they're web agnostic.
And you can use it in an React dev, or use
it in Ember because Thomas is sitting right
there and I have to mention Ember.
And they're really awesome because they interop
with everything.
Because they're browser language.
Anywhere you can use an input, you can use
this and that's awesome.
And that's what I work on.
But let's talk about art again as we were
already talking about.
So we make art with brushes.
We, like, paint on things, we, like, trace
things and we make apps with components and
better our brushes are, the better our art
is, or the easier our art is.
So the better our components are, the easier
our apps are going to be able to built, too.
So I just wanted to show you, I built this
really dumb app called emojillate.
And basically it takes an image and pixelates
it, and replaces every pixel with an emoji
and you can change the resolution so it has
more emoji, less emoji, and you can copy and
paste it, and send it to all of your friends
manipulated to tell you how I built this out
of web components because I thought that was
kind of fun.
So if you looked at this enormous app, we
have an input type="file," which is kind of
an OG web component so that's cool and then
we also have a paper slider.
So this is an element that my team works on,
and paper is code word for material design
at Google.
It was a terrible naming choice that now stuck
forever.
But that's a fancier slider because if you
ever try to style a native input type="range"
it's, like, 150 lines of CSS and pseudo-elements.
That's fancier slider and it looks pretty.
And in the middle, I have this giant emojillate
element.
And it basically collects things from the
files.
So it collects, like, the file contents and
then it collects things from the configuration.
So, like, the number of pixels on either side
and stuff like that, and every time it gets
changed, it gets updated.
And the reason why this is important is because
these changes are really easy if you've got,
like, a data-binding sort of system and that's
where Polymer comes into play because I told
you that I worked on Polymer.
So Polymer is kind of like jQuery.
I'm trying to, like, pitch this sentence about
it.
So I think Polymer is kind of like jQuery
for web components not in the sense that,
like, you don't need it anymore and everybody
hates it, and includes, like, seven versions
of it on their site but in the sense that
it sugars the DOM and makes DOM interactions
a bit easier while waiting for the DOM to
actually get a bit better because 15 years
ago, or 12 years ago I didn't write C++, writing
jQuery.
But writing child nodes and manipulating child
nodes and working on the DOM was kind of a
pain.
Well, Polymer now, web components are kind
of new and I secretly hope one day that we're
going to get native data binding on the web,
and I keep trying to pitch this to the link
team.
But the way that data binding works is if
you look at this emojillate element in the
middle, it has a file, and a file contents,
or whatever, and then of a an input type="file"
at the top and we're pretending that the API
is actually sane and it does which you want,
which it doesn't.
But if you had some file like containDataBlob,
then you could change it magically and say,
whenever this thing changes, teleport it over
here.
The reason why this is a lie is you need a
JavaScript to respond to that input type="file"
but, you know, it's nice in our dreams.
The resolution is nice, too.
So whenever move that slider and its value
changes, then the resolution changes and you
can put in a custom element.
And at this point I haven't written any JavaScript.
I've just written HTML and used data bindings
because Polymer have sugared it for me.
And I put in a checkbox because one of the
things that emojillate can do is help you
slow or hide the background image to make
it bit prettier.
So this emojillate element isn't really that
weird.
I wanted to show you that it's, like, platformy,
and not, like, this weird code that you're
not familiar with.
There are two parts of defining a web component.
You have so sort of provide prototypes, write
a class that says what that element does and
then you have to tell the browser to associate
a particular element with that prototype.
So that class is just a normal class that
extends an HTML element and then the second
part of it is saying, hey, browser, whenever
you see emojillate on an element, put it over
there.
And Polymer 2 is something that we're announcing
at IO.
Polymer is an extension, it extends an HTML
element, so basically it takes whatever you
would normally do and then adds some sugar
to it.
And then it wraps it all nicely in what we
call a taco because what I really like to
do is write my HTML in HTML, and my CSS in
CSS, and not JavaScript, I'm sorry.
And so one of the things that we can do in
Polymer is actually provide what this element
looks like in html.
So this element has a hidden canvas where
I'm rendering this pixelated image and it
has a hidden image where I've loaded the file
that you've given me and the code isn't really
hard.
I have a properties block.
I have some properties that this element cares
about like that file in resolution, and that
checkbox where I was binding and then I have,
like, JavaScript functions and then whenever
that resolution changes, I can just call an
observer and then it calls it for me.
Now, this isn't very hard.
You could write this in vanilla JavaScript,
it's just a getter and a setter for a thing
called resolution.
But you don't need to write it, you don't
have to write it, so that's why Polymer does
it for you.
It does all the heavy lifting for you.
That's all the code I'm going to show you.
So let's talk about art again.
How does emojillate actually work.
So it pixelates and adds emojis to it, and
that's why we have this dumb name but the
really interesting question was should it
use a canvas and should it use a span?
They're both going to look the same in the
end but I really wanted to use the span because
we're going back to this idea of sharing art.
I want people to be able to share these dumb
productions that you make with emojillate
and then if you share, you can copy and paste
it, and send it on Slack to all of your friends,
and everyone is going to be happy because
all your history is going to be blown forever
and ever.
My team's name was Voltron, and I think Sarah
Edo said this recently that every project,
and every team has named at some point Voltron,
and it's usually an awful combination of things
being glued together.
That's my team.
So how do we actually emojillate?
How does it actually work?
First thing we do is you load your file and
I put into a hidden image.
And this is the image that I'm using, it's
got lemons.
And then each to find the ratio of the canvas
so that your image isn't super wobbly.
So I'm going to widen the canvas and then
I'm going to pixelate it.
It's like something that we take a tiny image
and you stretch it out, and it looks like
an enormous potato.
So that's how we pixelate.
So you take an image and bam, pixels.
Now, if I wanted to pixelate it, I could stop
here, but we want to put an emoji on it.
So I'm going to divide this into a resolution
sort of grid because here it's eight chunks
that I want to split across and for each of
these chunks, the canvas API gives you an
array of every pixel in this file, so all
you have to do is go through a subarray of
the pixels and then pick a color.
So I would just pick a color that's closest
to the emoji in that blob.
And here I've done very bad things to the
RGB and assumed it's linear -- it's not.
So I'm just taking a linear distance -- it's
not correct.
It's kind of correct.
It's probably not the best emoji for that
but I don't care, it's art.
I can get away with this.
So every single blob for this, I keep doing
this and put the spans if the output.
So in the end, you get a giant pile of spans
that contain the emoji that are assorted that
the colors in that image it's going to be
warped because Slack doesn't use monospaced
fonts.
So it's like work lemons but it's fine because
we've made and you're trying to share that
with your friends which is exactly what you're
trying to do in the first place.
So all of that was made with web components
and because you can make web components you
should make like more awesome artsy web components
like a WordArt component from, like, Windows
95, or Windows 97, I don't remember which
of them, you have, like, a foreground emoji
and a background emoji and it says why your
text.
Good news, my coworker implemented this.
So this is a custom element that I've made
called an emoji picturing and you put your
emoji and text, and you make awesome things.
And because it's a web component, it's semantically
expressive, and it was called Emoji Art, and
it's doing what it's supposed to do, and you
don't need to know how it works because it's
scary.
So I want you to think of web components as
apps because that's what they are but in particular
I want you to think of them as tools to make
art and share art on the Internet because
that's what I really care about.
So do things, share things, tell people how
to pixelate their face and put an emoji on
it.
Thanks!